>>> WITH LESS THAN TWO MONTHS
UNTIL THE MID-ELECTIONS, NOT ALL
ADS HAVE BEEN ACCURATE.
LET'S BRING IN FACT CHECK
REPORTER DANIEL DALE.
YOU WATCHED THE ADS, WHAT DID
YOU FIND OUT?
>> I FOUND A FAIR BIT OF
DECEPTION.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT HAS
AN ATTACK AD.
IT SOUND LIKE O'ROURKE IS
CATEGORICALLY ENDORSING THE IDEA
OF DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
>> I REALLY LOVE THAT BLACK
LIVES MATTERS AND OWE PROTESTERS
HAVE PUT THIS FRONT AND CENTER
TO DEFUND POLICE FORCES.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM -- THAT IS
NOT A SENTENCE BETO O'ROURKE
EVER UTTERED.
IT TOOK A CENTERS FROM A PODCAST
INTERVIEW O'ROURKE DID TWO YEARS
AGO WHERE HE SPOKE SUPPORTIVELY
OF LINE ITEMS OF
OVERMILITARIZING THE POLICE AND
ATTACHED THE WORD DEFUND TO THE
WORDS POLICE FORCES, EVEN THOUGH
THOSE WERE ABOUT 55 WORDS APART.
AND OF COURSE THEY DID ATTACK
THE AD FOR WHAT HE DID SAY.
IN NOVEMBER THEY WERE DOING THE
SAME KIND OF THING.
O'ROURKE CAMPAIGN HAS SAID
CONSISTENTLY IN 21- 22 HE
OPPOSES DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
>> STREETS EXPLODED WITH DRUG
AND VIOLENCE WHILE LIBERALS
ATTACK OUR POLICE.
>> THAT CLAIM IS MISLEADING.
CONGRESSMAN RYAN HAS NEVER
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR DEFUNDING
POLICE AND HAS RELEASED THREE
SEPARATE TV ADS DURING THIS
CAMPAIGN EXPRESSING OPPOSITION
TO THE CONCEPT.
HERE'S A CLIP FROM THE FIRST
ONE.
>> DEFUNDING THE POLICE IS WAY
OFF THE MARK.
WE NEED MORE COPS, NOT LESS.
>> THE CAMPAIGN SENT ME A
COMMENT ON THIS WHICH YOU CAN
FIND IN MY ARTICLE ON CNN.COM
BUT IT DID NOT INCLUDE ANY
EVIDENCE OF RYAN DOING
DEFUNDING.
FINALLY MARK RONCHETTI HAS A NEW
AD OUT.
THE AD FEATURES HIS WIFE TELLING
THE STORY OF THEIR HOME BEING
BROKEN INTO.
LISTEN.
>> I HEARD THE DOOR SLAM
DOWNSTAIRS AND I KNEW SOMEBODY
WAS IN OUR HOUSE.
THE GIRLS WERE VERY UPSET.
I STARTED CRYING BECAUSE I WAS
SO SCARED.
>> NOW THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN
ABSOLUTELY FRIGHTENING ORDEAL OF
COURSE.
THE PROBLEM IS AS A BUNCH OF NEW
MEXICO MEDIA OUTLETS POINTED
OUT, THEY DIDN'T SAY IT HAPPENED
TEN YEARS AGO.
THEY ARGUED THE AD DIDN'T HAVE
TO MENS THAT, THEY'RE JUST
TELLING A PERSONAL STORY.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO TELL A TERNL
STORY ABOUT A FRIGHTENING
INCIDENT AT YOUR HOUSE AND THEN
ATTACK THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR,
IT WOULD BE MUCH MORE HONEST TO
MENTION THE INCIDENT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED UNDER A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR.
>> IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT YOU
WALKED US THROUGH ALL OF THOSE
DETAILS.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT.
>> THANK YOU.